this is the biggest bartending
competition in the country it's
aggressive it's a very aggressive [ __ ]
top one of us is gonna go on to win the
whole thing it's definitely a much
unique drink on a knife it's a dream
come true we have the list absolute
silence Carly Donovan's
I'm so proud that I was able
congratulations on making it to the
final ten so you guys are gonna have to
create a new drink tonight you're gonna
have to make enough for four judges and
four hundred consumers so we had to
batch everything for 400 people a gallon
of their these are 5 gallon the ratio
was a little funky and these aren't an
ounce
seven minutes your time starts now
so as far as my performance I did as the
show on the road here going overtime can
absolutely be the reason that I could
possibly not win today and that is the
few minutes late Julie watch Andy Thank
You Asians all right that stuff is over
all I can do is wait so just hung out
had fun and enjoyed watching the rest of
the people
the competition is the absolute most
professional interaction you will have
as a bartender in your life what was a
measure of gin per gram
these three people in front of you are
legit and they are judging every aspect
of how you handle that cocktail really
threw them off at the end
nerves can't get the best five four
three two oh yeah I don't have a clear
winner yeah winning the competition
immediately puts my bartending and our
work on the same level the potential is
huge
the it's huge it just kind of hit me
it's on you good yeah I'm running
another minute any time startsnow
awesome in the second round in front of
the USB gu judges it hit me that this
right now is the competition that was it
that was the moment where everything
counted everything counted we go with
the Bombay first
1/2 ounce of yellow chartreuse then an
ounce and a half per drink or Alison a
per drink yeah I'm shaken and 1/2 ounce
of coconut water it's a wash of thoughts
like is this drinking enough do I have
the right glassware is my garnish good
enough how am I putting my garnish on
like all of those things all the
logistics are running thin your mind in
split seconds and I just realized I'm
making four drinks like that you notice
I was trying to help you there at the
beginning okay sweet
alright then we've got a grapefruit with
brown sugar garnish we have the Busha
but my performance where the judges was
okay I've had a little pre-game jitters
miffed it a little bit but the cocktail
came out great so that's that's a
positive
I know we're a little surprised when you
have to make four drinks and I know she
only got a couple pieces of of cold
wrapped inside the shaker boo Louie are
we happy with the event I see got into
the shaker that's why I shook it a
little bit longer good thank you guys
all right thank you for that good job
thank you very much Monday and fall poem
tease them it's okay to run three cubes
of ice to it
the preparation was not there the the
practice too to be able to be thrown in
a situation where you had to on the fly
come up with the drink and all in the
same book so you have to be able to
technically perform it's over they got
the cocktail they're judging it my job
is done my drink is much way too long
there's not enough dilution needs to be
cut another 15% with water if it's gonna
be served like this well I think we can
move on I'm celebrating I'm in Vegas my
family's here my good friends and I'm
gonna go have fun the hardest part is
over with and now I just get to make
drinks for people which is what I do
it's nice to be back behind the bar and
just like making drinks for people
talking to people explaining my great
everybody that I gave the cocktail -
tonight was stoked about it thank you
thank you so I'm super nervous or
anxious ready to find out the winner I
have no idea I have no idea how things
are gonna shake out so we'll just have
to wait just tell us you wanna tell us
who won already
if I win having that title is a huge
deal will you announce the 2013 most
imaginative bartender
you